in The Matrix there's the woman in the
red dress and so it's one of the
training programs that Morpheus takes
Neo on to teach him one simple lesson
and so they're walking through a crowd
and then there's this woman in this red
dress walking towards and she's like
stands out from the crowd and Neo's head
and then he looks back and more if he's
like re-listing and he was like what
he's like were you looking into one of
the red dress and he says look again he
looks back at the woman it's agent Smith
pointing a gun to his head I see
distractions and New Opportunities shiny
object as the woman in the red dress
every level of business the woman in the
red dress becomes more and more
attractive because at first you have to
say no to thousand opportunities then
ten thousand then a hundred thousand you
have to learn how to say no again at
every level because I thought that once
I learned how to say no to the one in
the red dress I'd be done forever that's
not true she comes back every level she
just gets hotter and hotter and hotter
you get better and better and better and
so the quality of the red woman in the
red dress that you can attract is higher
when I look at the businesses that we
have I used to think that like
Innovation was everything the vast
majority of the business success is
actually doing all the stuff that you
know you should be doing but you aren't